[MUSIC PLAYING]
FERGUS HURLEY: Hey, everyone.
Thanks very much
for joining today.
My name is Fergus Hurley,
and I'm the product manager
for Android Vitals.
I'm really excited
to talk to you today
about the past, present, and
future of Android Vitals.
To start off, what
is Android Vitals?
I'm sure a lot of you guys
are aware of it already,
but just to make
sure, Android Vitals
is Google's initiative
to help improve
the stability and performance
of Android devices.
We're doing a lot
of different things
to be able to improve this.
One big part of it is
within the Play Console,
we now have a section
called Android Vitals.
And that's where we report
to you different performance
metrics we're going
to cover in this talk.
"How do we actually
power this product?"
is an interesting question
to start off with.
Well, hundreds of
millions of users
have opted into sharing their
device usage and diagnostics
data with Google and
you, our partners.
And so we share that data
in a privacy-compliant way
within the product.
I'm going to start by going
through some lessons we've
learned over the last 18 months
since we launched Vitals at I/O
last year from top
developers out there that
are big and small, that have
actually used Android Vitals
and got a lot of
success from using it.
So hands up here.
Who wants less one star ratings?
If you don't have
your hand up, you
might be at the wrong
conference, unfortunately.
But most people
want to avoid them.
And what we found when we
looked at the review corpus
on Google Play, which
is pretty large,
is that 40% of all
one star reviews
where we extract a
topic are talking
about stability and bugs.
And over the past
year, the percentage
of users talking about stability
and bugs in the reviews
has gone down by 18%,
which is pretty amazing.
So we're going to
talk about some
of the developers
who have actually
contributed to this reduction.
The "Merge Dragons" team, which
is behind a very popular Zynga
game, they used
Android Vitals to be
able to pinpoint where
specifically there
was an issue with
their application.
And this resulted in them being
able to reduce their one star
reviews by 50%.
The very popular Reddit
app used Android Vitals
to be able to reduce
their crash rate by 75%.
And they did this
because they were
able to see the category
benchmarks in the Play Console
Android Vitals section.
And that was able to make the
case with their leadership
that they had room
for improvement.
And then when they
actually improved
their metric, they were able
to show leadership, hey,
we've actually done
what we set out to do.
And now we're one of the
most stable apps out there.
The LOVOO team signed up
for the Anomaly Alert emails
in the Play Console.
And as a result,
they got notified
as soon as there was
an issue with the ANR
rate of their application.
They had a huge spike
caused by an SDK
that they were using
in their application.
And even though you might be
building an amazing product
yourself and think
that it's very stable,
I'm sure you've used
third party libraries.
And some of those
could introduce issues
in your application.
So you want to become
aware of these things
as soon as possible.
And the Anomaly Alert emails
help you with that a lot.
They quickly disabled the ads
SDK that was causing the issue.
And then they shipped a new fix
that actually reduced their ANR
rate back down to 0.25%.
The ABA English team
is a pretty small team.
And they don't have
infinite resources to be
able to spend on performance.
And we don't think that you
should spend all your time
focusing on performance either.
But we realize that you have to
keep an eye on performance all
the time, and that it
might make sense for you
to take a quarter to
actually just focus
on improving the performance
of your application
and hold off on new features.
Maybe do that as part
of your 2019 Q1 planning
or do a spring clean
for Q2 of next year.
The ABA English team did this.
And they spent one quarter,
focused effort, and reduced
their ANR rate by 97% as
a result. This and a bunch
of other things resulted in them
being to increase their star
rating to 4.6 stars.
Now, obviously, you can't
get a 4.6 star rating
but just focusing
on vitals, but we
guarantee that you'll never
get such a high rating
if you have terrible vitals.
So I've gone through some
examples of individual app
developers who are using vitals.
What we've actually also done
is we looked at of the top 1,000
apps on Play, we looked at
their engagement in the Vitals
section since I/O.
What we found is
that the developers who engaged
most in the Vitals section,
like the top 10%, they reduced
their crash rate by 50%
over that time period.
And this isn't just good
for those developers
and those apps.
This is really good
for Android N users.
This resulted in 3 billion
more stable installs
on the platform.
We've talked about stability.
Another major area
that users talk
about when they leave
one star reviews
is resource usage issues.
And this is battery,
network, memory, et cetera.
And we have many metrics in the
Vitals section around battery.
And some of these
metrics are interrelated.
So one of the metrics we have
is excessive network usage
in the background.
And so this is bad
for users in two ways.
It's consuming their data plan,
and it's wasting their battery
in the background.
We have two metrics
that we especially
focus on in this area.
They are wakeups and wakelocks.
I'm going to come
back to them in a bit.
But the Jaumo team focused
on their wakeups rate.
And what they say is
that they wouldn't
have even noticed or been able
to fix their excessive wakeups
issue without using Android
Vitals, because we have
a lot of insights into
your battery usage
that there are very few
other tools that can actually
help you with.
This resulted in them
being able to reduce
their excessive
wakeup rate by 70%.
Great.
Now we're going to jump over to
how you can actually increase
your five star reviews.
And what we find is
that over the past year,
we've had more users mentioning
speed, design, and usability,
which is what 70% of
the five star reviews
talk about when we are able
to find topics in them.
The MercadoLibre team, which is
one of the largest e-commerce
apps in the world--
it's number one
in Latin America--
they were building a new
feature into their application.
It required them to ask
for a specific permission.
This resulted in a
bad user experience
where users actually
had very high denial
rate of this permission.
There were able to see
that in Android Vitals,
and then be able to redesign
that feature to give users
an explanation of why they
needed it, that permission,
and only ask when the
users actually really
needed that for that
specific feature,
and not really early
on in the process.
The MercadoLibre team
is a pretty big team.
And one of the things they
found very useful with Vitals
is the ability to be
able to keep track
on many of the metrics
and be able to see
that at their startup time there
was a regression introduced,
which caused the startup
time of their application
to become very long.
And so they were able
to then figure out
which team specifically
had caused that issue,
and then work to be able
to debug that issue.
The LOVOO team used the
Android Vitals startup
time and the Firebase
Performance Monitoring tool
to be able to really get deep
insights into the startup
of their application.
So the Android Vitals covers the
platform-level data collection,
but doesn't cover exactly
in your application
where the issues might occur.
And so that's why we encourage
you to use Firebase Performance
Monitoring as well to be
able to understand where
specific issues are occurring.
They were able to figure
out that their login
and sign up flow was
taking way too long.
And they decide to do
a rewrite of that part
of the application.
So what's in Vitals today?
So Vitals consists of
five performance areas,
which I think
you'll all agree are
things that you
don't like to have
happen when you're using apps.
You don't want them to crash.
You don't want them to
drain all your battery.
You don't want them to be slow
in rendering or requesting
permissions they don't
need, or be slow to start.
And so we have 15 metrics
covering these five performance
areas today.
And across each
of these metrics,
we provide three dimensional
breakdown at a minimum.
So we show you OS version,
your APK breakdown, device
breakdown, and where relevant,
we provide other information
as well when it's possible.
A new feature that we
launched at I/O this year
is category benchmarks.
This is where you can
now be able to see,
compared to other
apps in your category,
how do you stack up
relatively so to your peers
across every single metric?
And we give you the
25th, 75th, and even
50th percentile breakdown
for each of those category
benchmarks.
And that can really
help you to be able
understand, OK, this metric
I'm doing OK on, and this one,
I'm actually falling way behind.
I need to invest there.
I mentioned the Anomaly
Alert emails earlier.
These are available
in the console.
You have to opt in
to receive them.
And so I encourage
you if you're not
opted in already to sign
up today and encourage
the rest of your team
to sign up as well.
This where we notify
you when there's
a significant change
in the ANR or crash
rate of your application where
we have a spike in the clusters
or across the core
vitals, which I'm
going to talk about right now.
There are 15 Android
Vitals metrics.
It's a lot of metrics.
We think all of them are
important to deliver the best
possible user
experience, but some
are more important than others.
As talked about earlier,
the leading contributions
to one star reviews are
stability issues and battery
issues.
So we have four core vitals that
are divided between those two
areas.
So crash rate and ANR rate--
ANR rate being Application
Not Responding--
are the two stability ones.
And stuck partial
wakelocks and excessive
wakeups being the two
in the battery area.
For each core vital, we provide
you a bad behavior threshold.
This is where if you're
above that threshold,
you're sort of
failing the class.
That bad behavior
threshold is established
by looking at the top
1,000 apps and seeing,
the bottom 25% of apps
are above this rate,
and so that's where
the bad behavior is.
We launched the Pre-Launch
Report a couple of years ago.
This is where when you upload
your APK to the Play Console
test tracks, we will generate
a report within an hour of how
your application performs across
those different 10 Android
devices that we
have in the Test Lab
when a robot is navigating
your application for about
10 minutes.
It gives you a report showing
you screenshot clustering
and a bunch of insights
into accessibility issues
and privacy issues,
and also flags crashes.
One thing we recently did
is that we enabled you
when you look at a crash
cluster in the Vitals section
to be able to see if we have
a Pre-Launch Report crash
that we've detected that matches
that crash from the field.
This is pretty useful, because
with the Pre-Launch Report,
these are test lab devices.
So there aren't the same
privacy restrictions in place
as there are with the data
from the field, of course.
And so here we are
able to show you
the video of the
robot interacting
with your application so
you can be able to quickly
reproduce that issue yourself.
And we've got a lot more logs
and detailed information.
We also did the reverse.
So we now have the ability to be
able to see when you're looking
at a Pre-Launch
Report, is this a crash
that is already
happening in the field?
Or is this one
that maybe just was
introduced with my latest
APK, but that hasn't actually
reached users yet?
We have over 100k developers
using Android Vitals today.
Hands up here.
Who's using Android Vitals?
Cool.
Great.
Thank you guys for using it.
One of the things that
I found most interesting
about this project
is that we've now
expanded the number of users who
are using performance metrics,
or what we call them,
like engineering metrics.
So I was previously working on
apps on another team at Google.
And I also did that
external to Google before.
And one of things I
really struggled with
was understanding how these
metrics were doing, because you
had to have the latest
version of the code
and be able to
run the profilers.
And now we've made
it so that it's
really easy for all the
people in your company
to be able to get access to
these performance metrics
and be able to see how
you're doing relatively so
to other people and make
the case for investing here
versus in other features.
I've shown some case studies
from different titles here.
And as you'd expect, you
have an Android engineer,
head of mobile engineering,
a product manager using it.
But now we have lead
mobile product managers
using performance metrics.
We have a CTO, VP of
product, and even COOs
using engineering metrics.
And so I encourage
you and your teams
all to start using these
metrics in your conversations
with your senior leadership
and with the wider team.
And if you don't,
you're probably
going to get left
behind, because quality
across the whole Android
ecosystem is improving.
Now, you might think,
OK, that's great.
That's impacting those
other developers,
but it's not impacting me.
My app's awesome.
Even though it says it
has a high crash rate,
I don't believe you.
Well, we looked at
the data of users
who experienced a high
crash rate versus users
who experienced a low
or medium crash rate.
What we find is that users
who have a higher crash
rate for the same app
leave 52% more one star
reviews or ratings than users
with a low or medium one.
And so really, I would encourage
you to start using Vitals today
if you're not.
Great.
So what is the future
of Android Vitals?
Well, we've built
a lot of features,
as you can tell so far.
And so really the
future of Android Vitals
is you guys using the product.
And so what we're going
to do is right now
we're going to try
something different.
And I want everyone to stand
up and talk to the people
beside you.
So you're trying to
find-- yeah, stand up.
Stand up, and find someone
beside you who hopefully you
haven't worked with.
And just introduce yourself.
And we're going to take
two minutes for one person
to talk about their vitals and
how they're approaching it,
and who in their company
uses it, what are the best
practices they've
found, and then
switch roles after two minutes.
I'll give you two minutes now,
and then we'll switch over.
So I hope you learned something
from the people you talked to
and made a new friend
hopefully as well.
So I would encourage you
to talk to other people
about how they're
approaching their vitals.
There's a lot of
documentation available online
to help you as well.
And we'll be at the
booth outside afterwards
just on the right-hand side
when you walk out of this room
if you've any questions as well.
One of the things
that you probably
realized talking
to that person is
that one of the biggest
problems with vitals
today is actionability.
And we've heard you
guys and your feedback.
We really appreciate that.
And I wanted to assure you that
that is something that we're
working hard to improve.
And we will have more to
come on that in the future.
We do believe that the data is
valid in terms of telling you
the direction to go,
as in like you're
doing good or bad
versus other people,
but we think we can
do better in terms
of helping you actually be
more efficient at fixing
the problem.
But that is a
really hard problem.
And we're working on changes
to the whole OS itself,
but those things take a while
to propagate across the Android
user base, and then to
have enough data to be
able to share back with
you within the console.
But it's definitely
something we are working on.
I want to thank you all very
much for joining us today.
And best of luck with
improving your vitals.
And I hope I get to
share your vitals success
stories in our talk next year.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]